you don't seem like the type of guy that
would watch The Bachelorette I watch
that I have not seen The Bachelorette
now I will uh when on and I are cooking
dinner there's a there's a little
ritual that happens where it's either we
watch Beat Bobby Flay because that's
sort of yeah I love it cook something
right and it's fine it's remarkably
entertaining and uh and then sometimes
there will be a real housewives uh
watching at the end of when we sit and
watch the dinner I'm fascinated by it I
really am I resisted it for for decades
I thought it was the low-hanging fruit
the lowest common denomi I can't I can't
with this it's a I would see them out in
the wild and you'd just see this pack of
cameras and lights just like what kind
of existence is this are you like are
you like me that you only watch The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills or are you
into these other franchises I only watch
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills yes I
watch that one because that one's on now
but the one that got me started
the first hit of the pipe
New York New Jersey New Jersey the New
Jersey one started in Jersey then we
went across the river to New York uh and
then we got on a plane and flew across
the country and landed in Beverly Hills
I can't get into the Salt Lake in the
Dubai and the me neither I can't I can't
get into the kind of ancillary markets
but everyone wants to know should Erica
Jane give back the earrings yes she
could absolutely these circular argument
that there she doesn't it's not
responsible you just want to shake her
and go honey
they were never yours give them back and
then I can't quite get are they are they
750 000 earrings or is it 750 000 per
year a piece I don't know
give them back